hello I am so excited to be in Paris for
the very first time talking to you about
crafting stateful styles now what do we
mean by crafting stateful styles
well the web is getting more and more
dynamic every day we don't have just
static web pages now we have web apps
and frameworks for those apps and we're
even making static web pages with those
frameworks for some reason so let's take
a normal button for instance we have a
fetch data button and so you might think
this is pretty easy to style however we
have many different ways that this
button can be represented so this button
can be in the hover State or it could be
active when you're clicking it or it
could even be disabled now these are
just the browser provide that stays for
this button but when you have certain
requirements from either your customers
or whichever company you're working with
you might need to represent a component
or UI in different ways such as a button
that's loading or a button that might
signal some sort of success or a button
that might signal that there's an error
and so these are all states that we have
to consider when were dialing these
dynamic user interfaces now typically
what we would do and what I have been
doing for a while before I sort of got a
better idea of what I should be doing is
adding classes in order to say which
state this should be in for instance
this button has a loading class and
we're gonna take a look at why this
might not be the most capable pattern
but first let me explain my journey to
how I got to where I am today you know
talking about steam machines all over
the place I wasn't actually always good
at JavaScript and I didn't even really
start off as a JavaScript developer I
started off as a pretty much a CSS
developer a web designer as it used to
be called and I made demos such as this
which is a really cool demo where you
could just hover over one that the you
know one of the weather things and see
the weather for a certain day now this
was done using only CSS and it was these
are all based on the animations
by 2bic studios and so I try to see how
far I could go with just CSS and HTML no
JavaScript at all even making something
like this calendar demo and so um you
know I I used a few tricks in order to
do this I found that check boxes are
actually really handy and doing some of
these complex styling so here's a trick
with the check box if you have a check
box that lives right next to your app
you could use the adjacent sibling
selector so that when that check box is
checked you could toggle that check box
with a label that has the exact same ID
as that check box ID and then using the
check su selector you could actually
affect the styles within the app and so
you can imagine if you add more than one
check box you could have multiple
different dynamic styles and different
things showing in your application all
without needing any JavaScript and so
this pattern proved really handy and
doing these CSS and the animations you
have check boxes where you could check
one or more to show and hide certain
things but I also used radio buttons
when I only wanted to show one thing at
a time and this is going to be an
important concept that we're going to
get into later so I started getting more
and more interesting what kinds of
things can we do with CSS without any
JavaScript and trying to push the limit
as far as I can you might remember the
CSS husky Bally made or recently I made
if this loads I made this Wow okay it
looks slightly better than the real
thing but this is the CSS cyber truck
it's supposed to be here I actually have
a backup over here but yes this is made
completely with CSS and I even used that
checkbox trick to make breakable windows
so if you see that
yeah thank you at least my demo went a
little bit better than Ilan so anyway so
as you know mentioned I do the key
framers almost every week with my friend
Shaw and we bring these imaginative user
interfaces to life from dribble or from
other places where there's all these
sort of dynamic interactions that need
to happen and we use HTML CSS in a
little bit of JavaScript but the more
that we were doing these the more that
we noticed these patterns of working
with States and we had to find a
scalable way to just not keep making the
same mistakes that we were making before
and actually find scalable patterns in
order to have these well I call stateful
styles and so we did this problem
presents itself in another way too
let's say that you're working with a
company you know your designer gives you
a certain design and you realize that
there's many different ways that this
application can be users many different
things that the user could do and so the
the designs that the designer gives you
aren't enough so it really comes from
both sides because developers - we we
tend to think of just like oh let's
throw this dial here let's you know do
this so we might have a button with a
class up loading a class of success but
what happens if we have both the loading
and the success class on the button and
how can you prevent that from happening
it doesn't really make sense I mean we
see this error exhibited in other ways
too so we want to prevent these
impossible states from happening and so
you might be thinking is there a better
way than to model these dynamics dates
for these dynamic user interfaces and so
I took a look at other prototyping tools
such as origami or envision app where
you define each of your screens and the
transitions that go between those
screens and make really cool animations
such as this or principle for Mac if
you've used principle that sort of works
in the same way it's like magic move on
steroids you could just drag things
around and it goes to the correct size
and also overflowed IO which is the
visual representation of the user flows
that
that represent each of the states that
your app can be in and so tools like
this are really good and I started to
see that all of these have certain
patterns they all represent your user
flows as transitions between certain
states and these transitions happen due
to events now this is also known as a
finite state machine and this is what
I'm going to be talking about area the
w3c in Aria defines a state as a you
know a dynamic property that expresses
characteristics of these components and
it also shows you that one in components
in a certain state it says nothing about
the character of the component but more
about what can be done for example if a
button is disabled you can't click it it
won't do anything and so we see this
exhibited in different ways as well and
you might have been using these finite
States and CSS without even knowing it
you might know hover focus active and
valid empty and all sorts of other
pseudo selectors but there's actually a
proposal for a native state pseudo
selector for custom components and so if
you're interested please go this link
and tell them that hey this would be
interesting to have in all browsers but
what I'm going to be using is data
attributes which are really fun to work
with and data attributes have this
unique property where you could only
have one at a time and we're gonna be
talking about what exactly that means
but data attributes are also really easy
to work with for example I could just
set the states to loading or I could set
the states to success just by changing
the property value or I could just
delete the the property and then that
data attribute is gone so here's what I
mean with data states we're no longer
polluting our class names or anything
with extra states for styling and we can
no longer reach that impossible state of
having something be both success and
error or loading or disabled and not
disabled so you could represent each of
your different states in that single
data state attribute
and so here's how this fits into a
finite state machine in the finite state
machine you have an initial state and
you have a finite number of states and
the rule with the finite state machine
is you could only be in one of those
states at any given time but the second
part too is there's these things called
transitions which dictate when this
event happens in your finite state
machine and you're in one state you will
always go to the states where all you
have to do is follow the arrow and you
know which state you're going to go to
every single time so you could use
finite state machines by doing switch
case statements where you give it the
current state you give it what events
happen and then you use those neset
switch case statements to figure out
what the next state is but I'd like
using optics mapping and with object
mapping it's sort of the same thing you
need a helper function to sort of just
walk through that object and figure out
what the next date is going to be but
the idea is exactly the same I created X
States and x8 is essentially that same
idea wrapped into a library you call the
Machine function you pass it in your
configuration which looks very close to
that object that I just showed you and
you could determine your finite States
now this is very useful for doing
dynamic things in applications such as
drag and drop where you have two states
you have dragging and idle and in each
of the states depending on what you're
doing you're changing certain values so
this I'm actually using I'm using the
data state attribute in a pseudo
selector to display what state I'm in as
I'm dragging this around and I also have
specific styling for each of those
different states so doing this with data
States means that you could do other
things to really customize the styles of
your stateful dynamic CSS for example I
could specify what the previous date was
and doing this allows me to define
certain Styles based on which transition
I'm going to so I might want to do
something different if I'm going from
idle to loading or something different
if I'm going from error to loading and
so we could just combine both of those
Dallas
in data Priebus Tate's attributes
together and figured that out or you
could do it a different way - I like
using a data transition attribute which
has both the previous date and the
current state and then you could use the
these darts the start attribute selector
the data of whatever you call it it has
a little caret in an equal and that's
what that is so let's see demo time and
so I use this technique over here when
when I actually created this because the
Styles do something different depending
on where you're going in so that's why
you see NAB one from starts start from
NAB one and then you could also go to
this date so we have nap two and back
over here and so this is the type of
dynamic user interface that really
benefits from having these strict Styles
based on transitions you know depending
on which state you're going to in which
state you're coming from this is another
example code thing that I did it's based
on a triple by gal Shearer who is an
amazing designer and this is a fun edit
your week app or you could just delete
all the weekdays and stretch out your
weekend and hopefully it does it for you
in real life but I had to break down
this animation and figure out what
exactly is going on so I realized
there's a start states and then there's
a selecting state when you're dragging
your mouse and then there's a selected
States and so from the selected state
now dragging your mouse does something
difference now we go to the dragging
state and so when you drag and you move
over the trashcan it goes to the
disposed State and then once you start
grabbing a state's now moving your mouse
does something different so these are
the exact same events but they're all
doing something completely different
depending on which state you're on and
so I use the finite state machine
I used X data actually in order to
create this and to style it using CSS as
well and so with this I was able to
generate a a graph of my application
logic automatically using that exact
same finite state machine
define within my application so not only
does it help me for styling but it helps
me visualize the logic I have and this
is why I think there's so much potential
in defining your user interfaces as
finite state machines and state charts
because you can do things like this and
more so in in more complex user
interface animations I even had to use
things like data show and data hide now
these are my own data attribute
selectors that I've created and you are
more than welcome to create your own
this sort of reminds me of angular
version one but I sort of like it still
so we have data show loading which means
show this element when we're in a
loading States and then we have data
hide loading which means the opposite
hide this element when we're in the
loading State and so what we could do is
we could add a little bit of JavaScript
and that JavaScript can help us
determine which one of these should be
active and so this is just a three-step
process first of all we set the data
state attribute on the application to
what state were in
and then we remove all of the data
active attributes just so that we have a
nice clean slate and then we determine
which one of the elements should be
showing or hiding basically which one of
the elements should have that data
active attributes so I use this in this
application over here which is also
available on co-dependant you go to the
link where you could do different things
in different states and things are
hiding or showing based on which state
they are which means that now we have
everything contained in one nice screen
instead of having to go to another
screen to another screen or having
things just jump out and hide and
disappear immediately like you're so
used to seeing in applications today
basically I'm saying that we have an
opportunity to create nicer styles and a
nicer user experience for our users by
using these data attribute selectors and
using these finite state machines in our
application and the key is instead of
thinking and just events and states we
think in transitions we don't think
about just what happened and we don't
think about just what state
when we think about what's the previous
dates what events occurred to transition
from that previous dates to the next
dates and was the overall transition
then we could visualize this in our
application and create these state
machines and state charts that we could
even hand off to a designer or another
stakeholder and get them to either
approve or reject or say this needs to
be that and just have a nice visual idea
of how our application is both supposed
to look and behave because our apps
aren't just about how they look anymore
they're about how are they supposed to
behave and what does the user expect
when they're playing around with the app
and doing certain things so with X
States you could also visualize your
state machines just like I talked about
by copying and pasting your machine code
right into the visualizer and it shows
you in a very dynamic way what happens
when you're in a certain state and a
certain event happens and then what the
next date is going to be and there's
other tools like this in the wild such
as sketch systems which is a really
really cool tool it shows you all of
your states in its own little DSL so
it's not exactly that object format it's
arguably easier to type but you visually
see which state your application is in
and then you could write a little bit of
prototype code such as this Google map
viewer that you see over here and you
could you could play around with it and
you could manually trigger States and
trigger events and get a very good idea
of what are all the possible states that
your app could be in so there's a lot of
resources for you available if you want
to get more into this subject I I could
only cover so much in 18 minutes there's
the world of state charts where it's a
nice gentle introduction to why we
should be using finite state machines
and state charts there's also the
spectrum community where you could ask
any question and it's a nice format for
just discussing all of these certain
things and also of course the x8
documentation at X das org slash Docs
and so basically my goal
is that we want to make our code do more
than just just doing whatever we're
asked to do like we don't want to make
our code just feel like class let's not
add loading we don't just want to make
our code do like I don't know disabling
a pion or something instead we should
make our code and organize it in a way
where we could analyze our application
and know exactly how many states are in
our application what all these states
are how these states connects to each
other what events happen and much more
than that and we could even use this to
automatically test visualize analyze
simulate our applications and more so
basically I want us to make our code do
more thank you so much CSS
[Applause]
[Music]